el 12 de febrero de 2014 en la ciudad de
Caracas estalló en protestas
Venezuela estaba sufriendo una de las
crisis económicas más importantes de
toda su historia la inflación ya estaba
despuntando la inseguridad y la
violencia acampaban a sus anchas y los
productos básicos eran cada vez más y
más escasos miles de manifestantes
estudiantes y trabajadores se rebelaron
contra el gobierno las marchas duraron
semanas y entre todos ellos hubo un
personaje que supuso un antes y un
después en la historia política de
Venezuela Leopoldo López
Leopoldo López fue Por así decirlo el
primer gran revolucionario contra el
gobierno de maduro fue precisamente él
quien alentó la oleada de protestas
ocurrida en 2014 y a diferencia de
muchos otros políticos de la oposición
Leopoldo López estuvo al pie del cañón
en las marchas liderando y abanderando
la manifestación contra el régimen La
pregunta es por qué es Leopoldo tan
importante en nuestra historia pues es
importante por la siguiente noticia 11
de septiembre de 2015 Leopoldo López 18
meses en prisión por incitar a la
protesta después de las protestas de
2014 el gobierno venezolano mandó a
restar a Leopoldo López bajo los cargos
de instigación a bellinquir
asociacionismo delictivo daños contra la
propiedad pública y En definitiva una
reta y la de acusaciones que en realidad
no eran más que una forma de maquillar
lo evidente Leopoldo López fue detenido
básicamente por ser una molestia para el
gobierno y era un opositor con poder que
había que quitarse de encima y el
régimen bolivariano No dudó ni un
segundo en hacerlo
sea como sea el arresto de Leopoldo no
fue la única calamidad antidemocrática
perchada por el régimen chavista al
mismo tiempo el gobierno de maduro usó
los servicios de inteligencia para
perseguir a multitud de opositores
torturó a rivales políticos y como
muchos recordaréis asesinó a decenas de
manifestantes en plena calle 23 de
febrero de 2014 ascienden a 10 las
muertes en las protestas en Venezuela
mientras continúan las manifestaciones
en 2014 se cruzaron todas las líneas
rojas que exige la democracia y amigos
eso tuvo consecuencias internacionales
muy directas
Obama firma una ley de sanciones
dirigida a los oficiales venezolanos en
marzo de 2014 tan solo un mes después
del inicio de las protestas lideradas
por Leopoldo López y de su posterior
encarcelamiento el congreso de los
Estados Unidos de común acuerdo con la
casa blanca de Barack Obama aprobó una
ley para sancionar a los líderes
venezolanos responsables de violar los
derechos humanos en su país
al principio las sanciones se dirigieron
contra personas en concreto congelando
sus cuentas corrientes y limitando sus
negocios en los Estados Unidos por
ejemplo uno de los sancionados fue
Antonio José Benavides comandante de la
guardia nacional y responsable de la
represión en las protestas contra el
gobierno otro sancionado fue Gustavo
Enrique González director del servicio
de inteligencia venezolano y asociado al
espionaje de opositores y a multitud de
detenciones extrajudiciales la pregunta
es qué pretendía el congreso
estadounidense Cuál era el plan que la
administración Obama había puesto sobre
la mesa pues lo que pretendían era
castigar personalmente a los represores
sin castigar al país en su conjunto ni
alentar tampoco un cambio de régimen
Obama simplemente quiso desincentivar
las malas actitudes de los miembros del
régimen para que estas no se repitieran
sin embargo en el año 2017 Todo cambió
un nuevo inquilino llegó a la casa
blanca y cambió el panorama
internacional de golpe y porrazo aquí
hablamos por supuesto de Donald Trump
[Música]
Donald Trump pasará la historia como el
presidente de la guerra comercial contra
china por su mítico stop de Kant o por
el prometido y nunca terminado Moro en
la frontera de México sin embargo eso no
es todo hay otro elemento que distinguió
la política de Trump un elemento al que
no se le suele prestar mucha atención
aquí estamos hablando de su política de
sanciones tras llegar al poder Donald
Trump se hinchó a repartir a diestro y
siniestros sanciones internacionales en
total se contaron más de 3.900 por
comparar ningún presidente anterior
había superado las 700 por supuesto
Venezuela no iba a ser una excepción en
este reparto de sanciones y en el año
2017 sucedió exactamente esto Trump
impone sanciones sobre Venezuela las
nuevas sanciones de Trump contra
Venezuela fueron mucho más duras que las
de Obama porque os acordáis de que Obama
tan solo castigó a algunas personas del
régimen en concreto no vuestra fue mucho
pero que mucho más allá
Trump bloqueo por completo el acceso del
gobierno venezolano al sistema
financiero de Estados Unidos y además
cortó por lo sano la repatriación de los
beneficios y las empresas del gobierno
venezolano tenían en los Estados Unidos
y sí estamos hablando sobre todo de
pedevesa en resumen las nuevas sanciones
de Trump dejaron a maduro sin poder
acceder a los beneficios y sin acceso al
nuevo crédito para costear su gobierno y
la pregunta es por qué Trump hizo todo
esto Pues básicamente lo hizo para
ahogar al gobierno de Venezuela Para
dejarle sin recursos debilitarlo todo lo
que fuese posible y así facilitar un
cambio de régimen nuestras sanciones se
han centrado en cortar cada fuente de
ingresos con las que maduro sostiene su
régimen totalitario y Criminal Donald
Trump en un comunicado de la casa blanca
como veis a diferencia de Obama que
simplemente quería desincentivar las
malas prácticas Donald Trump quiso dar
un vuelco completo al tablero político
de Venezuela su objetivo fue derrocar al
gobierno de maduro pero amigos la cosa
no quedó ahí en el año 2019 un nuevo
jugador entró en escena Juan guaidó
[Música]
tan solo dos años después del paquete de
sanciones de Trump el gobierno de
Venezuela se enfrentó a su mayor momento
de fragilidad hasta la fecha Juan guaidó
líder de la oposición se autoproclamó
presidente de Venezuela y suscitó una
rebelión que prometió acabar con el
régimen de maduro de una vez por todas
evidentemente Estados Unidos y Donald
Trump dieron todo su apoyo a guaidó Por
una parte le reconocieron como el
legítimo presidente de Venezuela pero
por la otra aplicaron un nuevo paquete
de sanciones y cabe todavía más duro que
el anterior en concreto estas nuevas
sanciones cortaron por lo sano las
compras estadounidenses de petróleo
venezolano y no solo eso sino que el
gobierno de Trump prácticamente obligó a
otros países a llevar a cabo un enorme
boicot con el que dejara Venezuela sin
compradores para su crudo Estados Unidos
ha ordenado a refinerías y comerciantes
de todo el mundo que corten su compra de
petróleo en Venezuela si no lo hacen
enfrentarán sanciones ya sabéis el dólar
estadounidense es la moneda
internacional por excelencia el dólar es
la moneda mayoritariamente utilizada
transacciones económicas a nivel global
y eso eso es algo que le permite al
gobierno gringo amenazar a países y
empresas extranjeras para que colaboren
en su política de sanciones básicamente
o estás del lado de Estados Unidos O
estás del lado de sus enemigos
Pues bien llegado el 2019 el gobierno de
Venezuela se encontró con serios
problemas económicos tras no poder
Acceder al sistema financiero
estadounidense perder los beneficios de
parte de sus empresas y encima sufrir un
duro embargo de petróleo por parte de
Estados Unidos y de sus aliados
conclusión
pues la conclusión es que en principio
todas las sanciones no sirvieron para
nada no al menos para cumplir su
objetivo principal el gobierno de maduro
sigue ahí tanto Leopoldo López como Juan
guaidó han pasado a la completa
irrelevancia y siendo Francos no parece
que esto vaya a cambiar en ningún
momento cercano por mucho que nos
prometan elecciones limpias en 2024 Pero
y si os dijera que todavía hay más y si
os dijera que las sanciones permitieron
a maduro consolidarse en el poder en
lugar de debilitarlo Pues sí tal cual
como lo escucháis y no solo eso sino que
según apuntan algunas teorías las
sanciones pudieron ser en realidad el
origen de la terrible crisis de
hiperinflación que sufrió Venezuela
durante estos últimos años Así que la
pregunta es cómo se explica todo esto
qué hay detrás de lo que os acabamos de
contar de verdad fueron tan
catastróficas las sanciones Pues ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver y sabéis que para
hablar de ello en esta ocasión tenemos
un invitado Oscar todo tuyo
[Música]
el castigo que se convirtió en premio
queridos amigos amigas es un placer
estar aquí en visualpolitik Aunque Más
allá de presentaciones la primera
pregunta que debemos hacernos es Cuáles
fueron las consecuencias de las
sanciones en Venezuela es verdad que
fueron las causantes de la crisis
hiperinflacionaria de 2017 pues vayamos
por orden
como hemos dicho el primer paquete de
sanciones de Donald Trump consistió en
cortar el acceso tanto del gobierno
venezolano como de las empresas públicas
al mercado financiero estadounidense en
principio esto es un problema que solo
debería afectar al estado sin embargo me
Temo que la cosa fue mucho más allá
porque os pregunto cuál diría es que es
la principal fuente de ingresos de la
economía venezolana pues efectivamente
el petróleo y la cuestión es que el
petróleo venezolano está monopolizado
por la empresa del gobierno la famosa
pedevesa y resulta que cuando Trump
cortó el acceso al mercado financiero
del gobierno pedevesa perdió el acceso a
créditos con los que pagar a proveedores
no pudo financiar fácilmente sus
inversiones Y por supuesto no pudo
llevar a cabo tareas de mantenimiento o
reestructuración de su deuda todo esto
junto a una pésima gestión a la
colocación de miles de amiguetes y a la
huida al extranjero de los mejores
profesionales de la empresa hicieron que
la producción de crudos se desplomara
Hablamos de una pérdida millonaria y
como ya os imaginaréis esto supuso un
duro golpe para el gobierno bolivariano
pero sobre todo supuso un mazazo para
los propios ciudadanos
[Música]
Y es que veréis para que Venezuela pueda
importar productos como medicinas o
alimentos necesita tener Divisas
internacionales Divisas que obtiene y
obtenía principalmente con la venta de
petróleo eso significa que cuando la
exportación de petróleo baja la
disponibilidad de productos esenciales
como los medicamentos también se reduce
Y esto es especialmente preocupante
teniendo en cuenta que Venezuela por
ejemplo tan solo es capaz de producir en
torno al 10% de todos los inputs que
necesita para garantizar el suministro
de productos farmacéuticos cosa que
quizá en menor medida también se aplica
alimentos ropa equipos informáticos o
cualquier otro tipo de importación
y claro si a esto le sumamos el embargo
de petróleo en 2019 el resultado según
apuntan estudios pesimistas es que más
de 300.000 personas estuvieron en riesgo
de quedarse sin tratamiento médico
aumentaron las muertes en más de 40.000
y el consumo calórico de las familias
cayó en pecado pero eso eso no fue ni
siquiera todo al perder el dinero del
petróleo el gobierno de Venezuela se
quedó sin Divisas con las que respaldar
el Bolívar la moneda venezolana Y de
nuevo según muchas teorías eso fue lo
que provocó la hiperinflación venezolana
de 2017 ahora bien quiero decir esto que
Venezuela se fue a pique por culpa de
las sanciones de Estados Unidos son las
teorías pesimistas realmente ciertas
pues amigos no vayamos tan deprisa
vamos a ver es cierto que las canciones
estadounidenses supusieron un duro golpe
para las familias venezolanas negarlo
simplemente sería absurdo ahora bien Lo
cierto es que los problemas de Venezuela
muy difícilmente se originaron a partir
de ellas por ejemplo sí las sanciones
pusieron difícil a pedevesa poder
financiarse para pagar a sus proveedores
pero es que en realidad ya mucho antes
de la ampliación de las sanciones
pedevesa ya tenía muchos pero que
muchísimos problemas para poder acceder
a crédito en concreto para el año 2017
la deuda de pedevesa ya alcanzaba los
30.000 millones de dólares era una
empresa prácticamente en ruinas en
quiebra y Los inversores Internacionales
se fiaba muy pero que muy poco de su
capacidad de pago y si queréis os pongo
un ejemplo empresas como goldman Sax tan
solo estuvieron dispuestas a financiar a
pdbesa tipos de interés disparaísimos
cercanos al 48%. o vamos En otras
palabras que los problemas de pedevesa
con la financiación muy probablemente
habrían surgido con o sin las sanciones
[Música]
ahora bien Por otra parte hay que tener
en cuenta que la producción de petróleo
en Venezuela ya venía cayendo
dramáticamente respecto al conjunto de
la OPEP y venía cayendo desde por lo
menos el año 2015 eso es dos años antes
de las acciones de Donald Trump Así que
la culpa de Esta caída estuvo más bien
en la gestión pésima en los costes
excesivos y por supuesto la corrupción
al más puro estilo bolivariano la
producción de crudo se desplomó por
culpa del gobierno no por culpa de las
sanciones que en todo caso simplemente
empeoraron una tendencia que la navaja
de por sí sea como sea qué hay de la
falta de acceso a medicamentos y comida
que supuestamente provocaron las
sanciones Pues de nuevo más de lo mismo
la capacidad de ingesta calórica de los
venezolanos o la importación de
medicamentos también se desplomaron
mucho antes de la llegada de las
sanciones internacionales por lo que en
conclusión aunque las sanciones pudieron
suponer un empeoramiento de la crisis
venezolana y esto nadie lo niega no
fueron el origen de los problemas de
Venezuela ni muchísimo menos pero sea
como sea Lo cierto es que en toda esta
historia sí que hay un factor de las
sanciones que pudo perjudicar muy
gravemente al país y ese factor no se
Comenta demasiado y ese factor es justo
el que os hemos comentado antes las
sanciones pudieron ser la herramienta
perfecta para mantener a maduro en el
poder Y diréis cómo es eso posible pues
presta mucha pero que mucha atención
[Música]
sanción o bendición
la teoría original de las sanciones dice
que sancionaron país sirve para dejar a
su gobierno sin recursos económicos y
tras ello dar pie a una Revolución
popular que acabe con él En el caso de
Venezuela los componentes de esta
estrategia estaban muy claros Por una
parte Estados Unidos limitó los recursos
financieros a maduro y a sus empresas
embargo la compra de petróleo y mientras
tanto apoyo a Juan guaidó para encabezar
la revolución contra el régimen no
obstante Pues el resultado fue todo lo
contrario a lo esperado maduro acabó
siendo más fuerte que nunca y guaidó
acabó siendo bueno Quién es bromas
aparte Lo cierto es que la teoría
original de las canciones pues acabó
fracasando estrepitosamente y la
cuestión es por qué lo hizo por qué
fueron tan mal las sanciones Por qué no
cumplieron su objetivo pues de hecho
fracasaron porque la teoría original
está mal Lo cierto es que las sanciones
económicas no suelen funcionar para
subvertir gobiernos dictatoriales ni
mucho menos para garantizar los Derechos
Humanos
veréis en un estudio del politólogo
darksen que contempló una muestra de 95
países que sufrieron sanciones entre
1981 y el año 2000 se encontró que las
sanciones a países con dictadores
aumentaron los abusos de poder
aumentaron los crímenes contra los
derechos humanos y En definitiva
consiguieron todo lo contrario a lo que
pretendían de alguna forma es como si
las sanciones en vez de derrocar a
gobiernos tiránicos les dieran más poder
Esto es algo que además otros estudios
han ratificado e incluso han llegado a
demostrar que Cuanto más duras eran las
sanciones y no solo eso sino que Cuanto
más países participen de ellas más
contraproducentes serán ojo esto no
quiere decir que sancionar siempre sea
contraproducente o que nunca tenga
sentido Por ejemplo en el caso de la
Guerra de Ucrania el objetivo de las
sanciones fue esencialmente debilitar a
corto medio y largo plazo las
capacidades militares y económicas de
Rusia su objetivo no fue propiciar un
cambio hace un régimen democrático en
ese escenario las sanciones sí que
pueden tener sentido Pero si la cuestión
es cambiar un gobierno para poner otro
nada de nada Cuando hablamos de que las
sanciones son contraproducentes hablamos
exclusivamente de que no sirven para
derrocar gobiernos dictatoriales y
establecer democracias que es justo lo
que se pretendía en Venezuela La
pregunta es por qué no sirven Qué hay de
malo en ellas
pues principalmente no sirven por dos
razones la primera es que cuando un país
recibe sanciones los gobiernos
dictatoriales efectivamente pierden
muchos recursos Como por ejemplo los
ingresos de petróleo El problema es que
para compensar esta falta de recursos
los dictadores empiezan a exprimir y
controlar mucho más el resto de la
economía del país y Un ejemplo muy claro
de ello lo podemos ver por ejemplo en
Irak veréis en el año 1995 las Naciones
Unidas establecieron duras sanciones
contra el régimen de Sadam husein en
Irak en concreto limitaron la cantidad
de petróleo que podía exportar el país
le dejaron lo justo y suficiente para
que el gobierno pudiera importar
alimentos para sus ciudadanos y cuál fue
la respuesta de Sadam husein a las
sanciones Pues el dictador Ire aquí
empezó a controlar por completo la
distribución de alimentos prohibió el
Libre Mercado de los ciudadanos y
distribuyó la comida mediante cartillas
de racionamiento a partir de entonces
cada familia en Irak tuvo que
registrarse en una especie de libro de
raciones alimenticias y justo gracias a
eso Sadam hussein obtuvo una base de
datos
de todos los ciudadanos iraquíes
constantemente actualizada quién nos
apuntará En esa lista pues simplemente
no comía esa base de datos por supuesto
fue utilizada por el gobierno para
reprimir a opositores políticos para
controlar quién comía o dejaba de comer
y En definitiva para aumentar su poder
tiránico Y es que si lo pensáis bien sin
las sanciones Sadam hussein nunca habría
tenido el incentivo ni quizá la
legitimidad para controlar la
distribución de alimentos y por tanto no
habría aumentado su poder en resumen lo
que pasa detrás de las sanciones es que
al recortar los recursos del gobierno
los dictadores se ven obligados a
subyugar todavía más a sus ciudadanos
con tal de seguir a flote
ahora bien todavía hay una segunda razón
por la que las sanciones pueden ayudar a
los dictadores y aumentar su represión
la razón del chivo expiatorio en este
vídeo hemos hablado de las teorías que
culpan a las sanciones de Estados Unidos
de provocar la hiperinflación el hambre
y la crisis en Venezuela tal y como
hemos visto esta historia son más bien
falsas o desde luego bastante pero que
bastante imprecisas sin embargo el
gobierno venezolano ha insistido en
numerosas ocasiones en que Estados
Unidos y sus sanciones tienen la culpa
de la crisis maduro culpa a las
restricciones impuestas por Estados
Unidos y la Unión Europea del
decrecimiento venezolano maduro culpa a
Estados Unidos de que Venezuela perdiera
el 99% de los ingresos en Divisas en 6
años como veis las acciones son una muy
buena forma con la que los dictadores
pues pueden desviar la atención de los
problemas reales de su país y es más
fácil culpar al malvado agresor al
imperialista Yankee asesino desde tu
colapso económico que asumir la culpa
hay perder legitimidad el problema de
todo esto es que mucha gente cree las
palabras de los dictadores y las
sanciones sirven como una forma de hacer
ver al dictador como un gran líder que
lucha contra las amenazas de los países
sancionadores algo que por cierto es muy
pero que muy habitual en América Latina
recordáis el tema del embargo Pues
básicamente eso en Cuba por ejemplo
Castro describió las sanciones
estadounidenses como un intento
imperialista de atentar contra la
independencia y la integridad del pueblo
cubano las sanciones por lo tanto
permitieron a Castro desviar la atención
pública de los problemas internos del
régimen comunista a la amenaza externa
planteada por las sanciones así a medida
que Castro se convirtió en un líder
Heroico que luchaba contra el poder
imperialista la coerción económica le
facilitó la justificación de su régimen
opresor en resumen las sanciones pueden
disparar los abusos de los dictadores
por dos vías primero obligándoles a
reprimir más para extraer nuevos
recursos y segundo legitimando sus
acciones culpando de todo a los países
sancionadores aunque he visto esto hay
algo que no queda del todo claro por qué
motivo entonces muchos países siguen
aplicando sanciones para derrocar a
regímenes dictatoriales Pues aquí por lo
menos tres hipótesis
la primera es que aunque las sanciones
en promedio no son exitosas en algunos
casos pueden acabar dando sus frutos la
segunda es que las sanciones pueden
tener objetivos ocultos Más allá de
propiciar la democracia y salvaguardar
los Derechos Humanos por ejemplo no
sería descabellado que las sanciones en
Venezuela tuvieran como objetivo
paralelo evitar el auge de los
movimientos socialistas revolucionarios
en el resto de América Latina y la
tercera es que aunque las sanciones no
funcionen demasiado una vez impuestas en
realidad tienen un enorme poder
disuasorio es decir ningún gobierno de
ningún país quiere ser sancionado de
forma que para evitar sanciones evitan
pasarse de la raya en ese sentido las
sanciones funcionan más como un castigo
y una disuasión que como una herramienta
correctora
sea como sea amigos Cabe destacar que
las sanciones no son la única forma de
castigar o desincentivar las malas
prácticas de los gobiernos autocráticos
recientemente de hecho se ha propuesto
alternativas como los sistemas zanahoria
sí zanahoria como el palo y la zanahoria
esta estrategia consiste en establecer
incentivos positivos a los gobiernos
poco democráticos para que digamos se
comporten adecuadamente aquí hablamos de
concesión de créditos baratos ayudas en
forma de subvenciones o la participación
en clubes internacionales sería una
filosofía de recompensa más que de
castigo pero sea como sea he visto todo
esto Ahora el turno es para todos
vosotros pensáis que la política de
sanciones en Venezuela estuvo bien
diseñada creéis que Donald Trump se
excedió y perjudicó al pueblo venezolano
de forma innecesaria qué haríais
vosotros para incentivar comportamientos
democráticos en países poco respetuosos
con los derechos civiles como siempre
podéis dejarnos vuestras impresiones en
los comentarios y así abrir debate Y si
este vídeo se ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros
al politik si es que aún no lo habéis
hecho una vez más Muchas gracias por
estar ahí un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]